veamos si podemos entender un par de
cosillas acerca de las curvas de futuros
y bien que aquí he dibujado dos curvas
de un año y bueno aquí lo importante es
que la diferencia entre estas dos curvas
es la liquidación de precios pactados
para fechas diferentes dentro de los
futuros ahora digamos que esta curva
naranja es una de ellas y lo que nos
dice es que si hoy antes de la fecha
pactada nosotros quisiéramos comprar o
vender una manzana y la tasa de mercado
son 10 centavos por libra y esto es
conocido como precio spot o precio de
mercado que es esencialmente el precio
en el mercado de la mercancía o
subyacente el día de hoy y básicamente
usando el ejemplo de las manzanas esto
nos dice que al tiempo cero puedes
comprar o vender una manzana basándonos
en el precio de los diez centavos que
están en el mercado ahora en el primer
caso digamos que sería dentro de un mes
y con esto no me estoy refiriendo a que
el precio del mercado subirá dentro de
un mes hoy lo que nos está queriendo
decir más bien es que hoy si llegas a
entrar al mercado de futuro si dijeras
quiero vender o quiero comprar manzanas
y lo quiero hacer dentro de un mes qué
tipo de precio pactado se podrá obtener
en nuestro futuro y aquí curva nos está
diciendo que podría hacer alrededor de
los 12 centavos y bueno quiero reordenar
lo que había dicho esto no nos dice que
dentro de un mes el precio del mercado
el precio spot estará en la alza sino lo
que nos quiere decir que el tiempo será
el precio spot está en 10 centavos esto
es exactamente ahora en el mercado y lo
que nos dice esto es que si quieres
entrar al contrato futuro por el precio
pactado dentro de un mes ese precio
pactado será de casi 12 centavos ahora
digamos si quieres pactar dentro de dos
meses el precio a tratar se estaría
forzando alrededor de los 15 centavos y
si ahora nos vamos hasta dentro de ocho
meses ese precio estaría alrededor de
los 20 centavos y todos estos
movimientos son de forma repentina pues
imagínate que las manzanas se vayan a la
alza o alguna otra fruta que no se era
para perder peso y la gente la demanda
demasiado por así decirlo y con estas
salsas lo que probablemente veas es que
esta curva completa se desplaza hacia
arriba y todo esto muy
independientemente de la fecha que se
haya pactado pues probablemente veas que
esto se va hacia arriba porque la gente
quiere o demanda manzanas durante todo
ese periodo cruzando nuestro tiempo en
el contrato bueno y esto hablando de las
salsas y este azul va a representar lo
mismo pero de las bajas en si la de
color anaranjado es la más normal si
está de pendiente positiva el azul nos
enfocaremos más en el siguiente vídeo
porque las salsas son como lo que
comúnmente se especula para la mayoría
de las mercancías o los commodities se
puede imaginar esto porque puedes porque
si este presupuesto no era con una
pendiente positiva o con esta dirección
no habría razón para ti de mantener algo
pues si esto va muy deprisa a la baja tú
debiste decir en el transcurso bueno si
este futuro tiene una fecha de entrega
yo estoy viendo puras bajas y no estoy
obteniendo ganancias pues yo simplemente
lo vendo en este momento y bueno de
hecho eso podría crear una presión hacia
la baja en el actual precio spot y claro
que con esto tú ya podría salir práctica
algo de arbitraje que bueno lo ver en
los siguientes vídeos porque finalmente
se debería decir un ajuste teórico en la
curva de bajas y su respectiva pendiente
y aquí tocando un poco acerca del
siguiente vídeo y bueno para el tipo de
las bajas a esta curva se le llama curva
invertida y esto es visualizando las
bajas pero cuando lo ver en el siguiente
vídeo